- Boy, they must have forgot
who we are.
- I think the internet forgot who we were.
- [Announcer:]
Touchdown, Kansas City!
-[Announcer 2:] He throws it
up into the third deck.
- Because this is gonna be
my lucky shirt.
- What you need?
- I need this off you.
- OK. OK. I'll send it to you.
- I'm not gonna put them
in the dryer.
- Thanks, guys!
- I'm gonna wear them next week!
- Super Bowl. Super Bowl.
- We're going to the big one!
- Super Bowl.
- [Man 1:] Welcome
to the playoffs, baby.
- [Man 2:] Hey, these games
ain't for everybody!
These games are for the elite!
- [Man 3:]
Just give all you got!
- [Man:] You know what time
it is, Chiefs Kingdom.
- [Announcer:]
The GOAT Tom Brady will make
his 43rd appearance
in a playoff game.
- TAMPA!
- Where else would you rather be
right now? Look at this.
- [Woman:]
Super excited to be here! Whoo!
- Let's go, Ravens, baby!
- [Announcer:] For Lamar
Jackson, he's either gonna
get over that playoff hump,
or the narrative will continue.
- Caw, caw!
- We're trying to work.
We're at work right now.
We just clocked in.
- Let's go, Buffalo!
Let's go, Buffalo!
- Aah!
- Hell yeah!
- [Announcer:]
We are set to go.
- Let's settle in, baby.
- I like this type of party.
- Yeah!
- Keep the camera on me, dawg,
cuz today I'm going crazy.
- I've been waiting
18 long years for this!
Go, Browns!
- Let's go get it done. Come on.
Championship mind-set.
One play at a time.
- This time last year,
we was considered
the worst team in the NFL!
But look where we at now!
- Don't run.
- Just don't run, now.
Make sure you go wherever I go!
- Whatever you got tonight,
I got to have it!
I need it all!
- Nothing else in the past
matters but this moment.
- We talked about
being warriors.
Well, one way or the other,
that's what you are!
That's who you are!
That's what we are!
- Hey. One job. Let's win.
- "Win" on 3, 1, 2, 3.
- Win!
- Go, Bills!
- Man, win or go home.
- We ain't going home.
- I ain't trying to go home.
- Hell no.
- Playoff football, baby.
It's the only way to do it.
- [Al Michaels:] And they start
with a horrible snap.
And the Browns
wind up with a touchdown!
- 18 years
since our last playoffs,
and the Browns score a defensive
touchdown off a fumble.
I'm not getting off
this treadmill
for the rest of my life.
- [Announcer:] Hardman
standing in his 11-yard line.
Drops it! Muffs it!
Bills' ball on the 3-yard line.
- Look at me. Hey. Look at me.
Hey. We're good.
Just be you. You're gonna
make a play this game.
- [Announcer:]
Brady has all kinds of time.
Throws toward the end zone.
Touchdown!
What a way to start
the football game.
- [Man:] Bucs strike first!
Oh, baby, we got a game
in Lambeau!
- [Announcer:] They throw it
left side to Hardman
on a wide receiver screen
into the end zone! Touchdown!
- Hey! That's how
you handle adversity!
You smack it right in the mouth!
- [Announcer:]
Quick toss. Davante's got it!
And the Rams got crossed up!
- Jalen Ramsey, ya got burned!
- We got it. Let's go.
- [Announcer:] Steps up.
Pocket collapsing. He escapes.
Lamar Jackson to the 20.
Leg race. 10. 5.
- That's what we're talkin'
about! Easy money! Let's go!
- Easy money!
- Yeah! Ha ha!
- Yeah!
- Feel it, baby!
- Keep it going. Keep on going.
Hmm. Oh, yeah. Hell yeah.
♪♪♪
- Yeah!
- [Laughing]
- [Announcer:] It's probably
gonna be a good couple of weeks
for folding table
and picnic bench makers
in the Buffalo area.
- They can take
their hats and T-shirts to Cabo!
- Still wanna laugh at us?
- You hear me?
- We're the same old Browns.
Remember that.
- You can TikTok
all the way to fishin', buddy.
You can fish all night long.
- Who can't win a playoff game?!
- [Man:] Lamar!
Ohh! Ohh! Ohh! Ohh!
- I need something
from you, though.
- What you need?
- I need this off you.
- OK. OK. I'll send it to you.
All right, man.
Good luck to you.
- I'm tellin' you.
Y'all better wake up!
- I'm-a put the dagger in 'em.
- [Announcer:]
Throw the bubble. Picked!
- Pick-six, baby! Yeah! Whoo!
- [Steve Levy:]
Tannehill steps and fires.
And it's intercepted!
- Aah! Ha ha! Yeah!
Yee-yee-yee-yee-yee!
- [Announcer:] They're out there
stomping on the logo.
- The disrespect!
- [Announcer:]
Pass is intercepted!
It's the Honey Badger!
- You get a pick!
You get a pick! You get a pick!
- [Announcer:]
Picked off by Devin White.
- Beatdown!
- We eatin' W's.
- [Michaels:] Jackson fires.
And that will be intercepted
in the end zone
by Taron Johnson!
And only Jackson
can stop him now.
Too late. To the end zone.
Touchdown!
- [Cris Collinsworth:]
And the Buffalo Bills
have all of Buffalo rocking
like they haven't been rocking
in 20-some years.
- Always put the money on me.
- [Tracy Wolfson:]
It is official.
The Chiefs will not have
Patrick Mahomes
for the rest of this game.
- [Announcer:] Chad Henne
coming into the game.
- If somebody told you
it was gonna be hard,
would you still want it?
Hell yeah!
- [Announcer:] If the Chiefs get
a first down, the game's over.
Henne scrambling
and comes to the near side.
He's at the 40, 45, 50.
- Chad Henne, baby! Let's go!
- [Announcer:] They snap it.
- There is a play.
They're going for it.
They flood it right. Caught.
Tyreek Hill. Stays in bounds!
- Henne-thing is possible!
- [Announcer:]
Packers get a score here
and a 2-point conversion
to get this thing tied.
Rodgers steps up, scrambles.
Throws late over the middle.
Incomplete.
My goodness.
- Oh. Kick-- Kick it.
- [Announcer:] Wow. You would
have liked to have seen them
get it done there.
- Hey. We got three time-outs.
- What?
- They're kicking a field goal.
- Why?
- [Aikman:] I thought
that they would go for it
on fourth down.
- [Man:] Me too, Troy. Me too.
- Need me to illustrate
why that's so dumb or--
Now or later?
- No penalties.
Take care of the ball.
Good routes. Everything.
- [Announcer:] Do you have
a play in your playbook
that will secure a first down
and a victory?
Godwin running to the --
He's got the first down!
- Let's go! Let's go!
- Argument closed!
Who's the GOAT? Tom Brady!
-I really look up to you too, man.
Man, keep your head up.
- [Romo:] What a season
by Cleveland getting here.
- [Nantz:] I know there
are hearts broken today,
but they're not
the same old Browns anymore.
- You've done a hell of a job.
That's the most important thing
right there, huh?
Most important thing.
- Good luck, man.
- Thank you.
- Go get another one!
- [Man:]
This is the proudest I've been
of this team in almost 30 years.
- I'm off to the store
because I need ice cream.
Chocolate ice cream.
- [Announcer:] You can't help
but wonder as we watch
Drew Brees walk off
this football field --
is this the final time that
we're gonna watch Drew do this?
- [Announcer:] Tampa Bay
Buccaneers are going to be
the first team ever
to host a Super bowl!
- [Crying]
I waited so long for this.
- There's a ceremony?
- Yeah.
- There's like a ceremony?
- I'm new to this, man.
- We're coming home,
and we're coming home to win.
- We still ain't played
our best yet.
- Nope.
- We going again, baby!
- I'm back!
- [Announcer:]
Back-to-back AFC titles.
- We back!
- Let's go!
Aaaah!
- [Romo:] It's Mahomes/Brady.
Super Bowl!
- I'll see y'all in Tampa Bay!
- [Woman:] Ohh!
- There he goes.
- Ohh!
- I could've used you tonight!
- Tommy, if you're watching,
which I know you're not,
we're coming for you
in two weeks.
- No more "Suck-aneers" no more.
I don't want nobody
calling us Suck-aneers anymore.
- Have fun.
Be nice to your sister.
- No!
- Yes. Be nice to your sister.
See you, boys.